[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78
également diffusé sur un radio
sensations dans le cadre du premier tour
des élections municipales débat
aujourd'hui consacré à la verrière
quatre listes sont déclarés au 8 février
celle de nelly duthu maire sortante
listes de gauche celle de jean yves blé
qui a quitté la majorité en cours de
mandat celle de nicolas dainville liste
portée notamment par l'opposition de
droite du sandre mais pas uniquement
nous y reviendrons et puis une quatrième
liste celle menée par gérard claude
morfin elle est encore en cours
d'élaboration
elle ce dernier n'a pas souhaité
participer à cette émission son
interview est néanmoins retrouver comme
pour l'ensemble des candidats sur notre
site internet en replay trois candidats
vont donc échanger sur ce plateau
je voulais présente dans un instant
juste après ce sujet qui fait le point
sur quelques uns des enjeux à la
verrière commune historique de la ville
nouvelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
verrière compte plus de 6000 habitants
une ville touchée par des problématiques
sociales un taux de chômage de 16 % le
taux de pauvreté atteint près de 24%
l'insertion et l'emploi des verriers
roide de sujets sur lesquels la future
majorité pourra agir en collaboration
avec d'autres collectivités
un sujet lié à l'éducation et la
scolarité dès le plus jeune âge
la lutte contre la délinquance est aussi
un sujet pris en compte par les
candidats la verrière touchée aussi par
le phénomène de désert médical le manque
de médecins et de professionnels de
santé sur la commune pose des
difficultés d'accès aux soins des
projets d'aménagement sur la ville
d'abord la rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang un sujet qui divise d'un
côté une rénovation sur les bâtiments
existants
de l'autre une destruction
reconstruction partielle de certains
immeubles autres quartiers de la
verrière orly parc concerné par
plusieurs projets d'aménagement
autre projet d'urbanisation
intercommunale menée conjointement avec
saint quentin en yvelines le projet
urbain gare bécane 1800 logements une
zone d'activité économique et un pôle de
transport multimodal
juste à côté le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit son enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront reliés au cours de ce débat le
temps de parole sera chronométré pour
assurer au mieux l'égalité entre chacun
des candidats nous allons d
avec un premier tour de table jean yves
blé est candidat également à cette
élection nous rejoindra en cours de
cette émission il a eu un peu de retard
nous avons fait un tirage au sort
néanmoins et c'est nelly du tout qui va
débuter prendre la parole en premier
tête de liste la verrière en commun
première question comme pour les autres
candidats pourquoi les électeurs
devraient vous choisir pourquoi faire
votre choix
pourquoi ce choix vers vous tout
simplement non parce que je pense que
jusqu'en je suis sur la verrière depuis
17 ans maintenant
j'ai connu cette ville par
l'intermédiaire déjà de mon bénévolat au
secours populaire
et c'est parce qu'elle me semblait
extrêmement sympathique c'est lui que
j'ai fait le choix de m'y installer
et ensuite le hasard a voulu que que
monsieur ajaj tombe malade et s'en aille
pour que je prenne la suite
donc ça fait 4 heures maintenant que je
suis en poste que j'ai pris mes marques
parce qu'il faut un petit peu quand même
que je sais que on a fait en sorte que
ce bill le
le projet de 2014 soit respectée
maintenant maintenant j'ai envie de
défendre un projet qui est le mien est
qui qui va de l'avant qui est assez
renouvelée par rapport à d'habitude donc
je je je suis consciente de mon de mon
bilan je l'assumé je le pense positif et
je pense qu'on peut faire encore mieux
pour la prochaine fois parce que je ne
les ai pas préciser tout à l'heure vous
n'avez pas été élue directement au tour
l'élection précédente en 2014 c'est à
linge âge qui avait été élu et vous avez
récupéré ensuite l'écharpé tricolore
après son départ en 2016 nicolas hédin
ville
je disais tout à l'heure votre liste et
vous allez le corriger sans doute été
plutôt à droite vous vous êtes en tout
cas sensibilités politiques les
républicains de votre liste et
apolitique fait plusieurs années que je
suis sur le terrain au service des
verreries roi avec mon équipe une équipe
de sensibilités diverses
parce qu'on pense qu'il faut apporter
des compétences et pas forcément est
dans une logique partisane
les verriers roi sur le terrain ce qu'il
me dit c'est qu'il ya un vrai
attachement à la verrière c'est une
ville qu'on aime tous ils sont attachés
mais il ya aussi un sentiment d'abandon
face à la montée des incivilités il ya
une colère parfois face à ce qu'il
qualifie de passe droit il ya une envie
que la ville soit plus vivante et un
service de de santé le plus développé
avec des médecins on a zéro médecin dans
une ville de 6000 habitants
c'est quand même quelque chose qui n'est
pas acceptable et puis il ya une envie
de proposer un nouveau projet un nouveau
souffle
on a aujourd'hui une majorité divisée
monsieur blé qui n'est pas là partir
toujours à la majorité ce jour le
premier adjoint de la maire sortante et
ses divisions la et nuisent à l'avancée
des projets c'est une réalité qu'il faut
avoir une équipe soudée diversifiée avec
un cap clair pour la vie plus dynamique
plus vivante plus sûr et plus belle
encore vous êtes à une minute à peu près
de temps de parole à chacun gens ils
voulaient effectivement qui nous a pas
encore rejoint mais qui fait partie de
cette majorité il s'en est écarté il ya
tout juste un an avec une dizaine
d'autres élus avec un groupe au sein du
conseil municipal
les deux anciens maires pendant cette
campagne le soutiennent aujourd'hui nous
parlons des différentes thématiques à
présent parlons et urbanisme question de
l'urbanisme qui va occuper le prochain
mandat
plusieurs chantiers d'envergure sur
cette commune
réhabilitation parfois comme bois de
l'étang réaménagement comme au carrefour
de la malle me donne situé au croisement
de coignières la verrière maurepas ou
encore réalisation de quartier tout
simplement on pourrait aussi penser à la
zone d'activités des bécanes pendant que
jean yves lennon rejoint bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau où nous venions
juste de faire un tour de table de
présentation nous avons présentées en
votre absence
elle nous commençons donc cette
thématique d'urbanisme pour ce débat sur
la verrière nelly duthu vos positions
déjà peut-être concernant le bois de
l'étang il ya eu un débat faut-il
détruire pas détruire construire quelle
est aujourd'hui quel est votre projet
pour ce quartier on est à temps plein en
pleine réflexion avec les habitants ça
fait déjà deux d'une année une bonne
année et demie que tous les un mois et
demi on se réunit avec les habitants
pour discuter du projet il y avait
effectivement
la question de démolition pas qui a
accaparé beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
normal parce que les habitants sont
inquiets de savoir ce qu'ils vont
devenir
donc
rien de plus normal que ça mais au bout
d'un moment il a fallu se positionner
pour que le projet avance et je me suis
positionné contre c'est pour ça que le
reportage est un peu date un peu je
pense je sais présentation des
différents je suis pro positionner
contre les démolitions mai mais avec une
rénovation de grande
de grande qualité donc c'est pas là pour
votre point de vue sur le bois de
l'étang je vous fait réagir également
nicolas dainville globalement on parle
d'urbanisme à présent juste un petit
ajustement technique
monsieur blé si vous pouviez vous
rapprochez un tout petit peu pour être
bien face aux micros voilà fait les
ajustements en direct également nicolas
dainville à présent effectivement sur ce
dossier de l'anru au bois de l'étang
c'est un dossier qui est sorti du
chapeau je dire un peu en catimini sans
que les habitants ne les découverts
pendant les élections de 2014 dont
beaucoup sont tombés des nues
ils ont compris que qui dit démolition
dire logement moi je m'appuie beaucoup
sur ce qui s'est fait au petit prêt à
l'époque au petit pré projet aussi de
démolition du quartier à elancourt et
beaucoup d'habitants ont répondu à une
enquête sociale qui permettait de voir
leur désiratas et on s'est rendu compte
que très peu d'habitants pourraient être
logés sur place que ça allait à être
pour 70% d'entre eux plus loin plus cher
et plus petit parce qu'on fait pas
aujourd'hui de d'aussi grands
appartements combat de l'étang donc moi
je me suis aussi positionnés très
clairement sur une rénovation ambitieuse
sans démolition donc que les choses
soient très claires en mobilisant des
fonds des moyens pour réaliser un
certain nombre de choses
je pense que la question des parkings et
de l'espace public est important pour
clarifier qui fait quoi entre le
bailleur et entre la ville notamment
c'est aujourd'hui quelque chose qui est
pas satisfaisant
la question des lignes à haute tension
qu'il faut enfouir on s'est battus au
niveau de l'agglomération pour que
l'enfouissement des lignes à haute
tension du bois de l'étang soit enfui en
même temps que celle des rayons vous
savez c'est la même ligne donc quand
enfin l'enfouissement des réseaux
on fera l'enfouissement du bois de
l'étang donc c'est quelque chose
d'important reste à trouver les moyens
ça peu près 30 millions d'euros donc
c'est une somme importante il faut se
bouger pour essayer de les obtenir
et puis sur le pont de la ville dieu qui
est l'entrée de ville l'entrée du
quartier
il faut aussi se battre pour le doublé
pour fluidifier ce passage c'est aussi
30 millions d'euros aujourd'hui le
financement est bouclé
département-région agglomérations mais
donc je pense que si on arrive
à réaliser cela avec des rénovations des
intérieurs fauniques notamment pour
lutter contre les nuisances du bruit
énergétique pour mieux consommer et les
aménagements paysagers
je pense qu'on peut avoir une rénovation
ambitieuse sans démolition
voilà pour ce quartier où vous l'avez
compris la question de l'urbanisme qui
est important qu'ils se retrouvent à
travers les différentes listes également
pour vous jean yves blais donc également
candidat sur cette élection municipale à
la verrière sur la question du bois de
l'étang spécifiquement vous avez un
projet un peu différent oui tout à fait
bonjour d'abord désolé pour le retard
sur sur la question de l'anru monsieur
david hill et arrive en catimini
c'est pas tout à fait faux mais c'est
pas tout à fait vrai non plus ce qu'il
faut c'est bien regarder la ville dans
son ensemble et pas simplement par un
petit bout de la lorgnette c'est à dire
que on regarde le bois de l'étang et
puis pas le reste je vous rappelle que
quand même on est un grand sujet qui est
guéri cannes avec un projet
d'écoquartier sur celui ci qui
consommera peu près 1500 logements
concernant revenir au bois de l'étang
concernant le bois de l'étang en effet
notre équipe nous nous disons que nous
sommes pour une démolition partielle
parce que nous pensons que pour avoir
les crédits d'un re il faut en passer
par là et que si nous voulons ce que dit
madame doute eu des logements de qualité
de haute qualité il faut aussi avoir des
crédits pour ça et je pense pas moi que
bailleur séquence à lui seul pourrait
financer cela donc de ce point de vue là
je pense qu'il a on a en effet des
divergences moi ce que je voudrais dire
aussi c'est que concernant ce projet si
on l'a inscrit tardivement dans notre
programme
à l'époque c'est parce que on n'avait
pas tout à fait là le regard global sur
notre commune et que au fil de l'eau en
discutant et en réalisant finalement par
des enquêtes publiques ont amené sur
gare bekale que la tension aussi se
portaient sur sur le bois de l'étang et
donc il fallait là pour un une question
d'équilibré aussi d'attractivité vous
rappelle qu'on a fait deux programmes
d'accession à la propriété qui nous pose
de jolis quelques difficultés parce
qu'on vend pas tout parce que des gens
revendent parce que donc là il ya un
souci là à à prendre en compte et donc
on a besoin de remettre la un peu
d'attractivité pour faire revivre ce
quartier voilà j'ajouterai par ailleurs
que nous avons menées
nous du porte à porte je sais que tout
le monde le fait mais enfin bon je
l'avais fait en son temps avec avec
nelly les habitants nous disent on n'est
pas contre la démolition
bien au contraire je les vient de
terminer une série de porte à porte sur
ce même quartier
récemment et les discours est un jour le
musée moi pourquoi pas que vous
dépassiez trop à votre temps paroles
sincères mais je vous dis les choses
telles qu'elles se passent autrement dit
les gens ne sont pas contre il voit
aussi ce qui se passe ailleurs
moi je veux bien les petits prêts mais
il faut aussi regarder ce qui se passe à
trappes il faut six que regarder ce qui
s'est passé à poissy enfin je vais pas
énumérer toutes les villes qui sont dans
ce schéma là donc voilà je pense pas que
nous sommes nous à côté d'eux des choses
walid utile vous souhaitez réagir et
nicolas danville a ensuite nommé juste
badge m'aperçois que monsieur david est
d'accord avec nous donc j'en suis forte
heureuse puisque tout ce que vous avez
développé sont des choses qui sont
développés dans les conseils de vie
d'étoilé gaz de rénovation mais je
corrige ce que vous dites donc tout ce
que vous avez développé s'est développée
dans les conseils de ville et de
voisinage ont été pris en compte par les
urbanistes et les architectes donc on va
mener la bataille ensemble pour aller
alors nicolas mainville
alors pour rebondir sur ce que dit le
premier adjoint effectivement sur les
bécanes les bécanes c'est un des projets
essentiels pour améliorer cette
attractivité de la commune qu'on appelle
tous de nos voeux par contre faut pas le
faire n'importe comment c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est battus en tout cas en tant
que conseiller départemental pour qui un
projet plus qualitatif et - quantitatif
que ce soit pas les 1800 ou les 2200 qui
était même évoquée logement mais que ce
soit que 1000 logements que ce projet de
1000 logements il a été voté à la fois
au conseil municipal et au conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc il s'agit
bien de 1000 logements avec un curseur
sur l'accession à la propriété pour
offrir aussi un autre type d'habitat
donc pour 75% de sa fraise 750 logements
en accession à la propriété
250 logements pour les locataires donc
la dimension sociale donc c'est un
projet très important
je sais que c'est une divergence combat
puisque vous vous défendez 1500
logements ce qui nous nous sommes trop
quantitatif trop trop massif
je pense qu'il faut toujours prendre en
compte la logique de circulation de
stationnement
et puis un maîtrise mans maîtriser c'est
sur une dizaine d'années donc voilà déjà
faisant nos 1000 logements améliorons
cette attractivité et je pense que ça
jouera positivement y compris sur les
finances notre commune n'est dû tuer
ensuite j'en ai vu blé vous avez le sens
la v2 de minutes de temps après on est
on est passé sur la saga bécane si les
yeux je vous laisse réagir parce qu'ils
sont restés si j'ai bien compris la
discussion glisse vers la suite des
dossiers d'urbanisme effectivement
l'asacar je tiens quand même à signaler
que ce projet a été bloqué pendant deux
ans par l'agglomération on n'a pas plus
avancé aujourd'hui si ça ne devrait pas
été le cas
les premiers bâtiments sortirait de
terre quand je suis devenu maire ma
première préoccupation une de mes
premières préoccupations a été de
débloquer la situation est en fête avec
l'agglomération on a discuté de façon à
débloquer cette situation mais elle a
été volontaire de ma part et si on est
tombé d'accord c'est aussi parce que
les fondamentaux que je défends des dès
le début ont été respectées les 25 % de
logements sociaux c'était pas ça au
départ c'était pas plus de vingt même
voire moins donc la loi nous a aidé à
stopper d'accord d'ailleurs mais quand
vous parlez de 2
de privatif n'oubliez pas de dire qu'il
ya différents types d'accession et que
je prône 30 % en accession aidée à la
propriété ce qui change un peu la donne
quand même effectivement l'accession à
la propriété c'est plus large avec une
accession aidée
voilà des taux de tva réduits des
location-accession y at il un type tout
d'accession qui est bien sûr défendu
jean yves les vous écoute sur ce dossier
sur tarn et cannes lions un dernier mot
sur
sur le bois de l'étang quand même
concernant la leur logement on peut tout
à fait relogées sur le parc dans un
opération tiroir ont fait bloquer les
attributions et on peut glisser
tranquillement les gens pour qu'ils ont
démoli ray sur le parc existant
voilà on ferme la parenthèse et j'ouvre
sur sur la question sur d'ailleurs des
cannes et sur la manière mécanique de
logement par exemple moi je veux je
m'interroge comme monsieur le conseiller
départemental 10 qui s'est bâtie pour
regarder kahn s'il s'était réellement
battus nous serions à 300 logements
sorti de terre aujourd'hui pour un autre
projet oui oui j'ai bien compris pas le
vôtre mais notre projet était tout à
fait équilibré votée par le parlement
sert par le conseil communautaire voter
approuvé par le préfet approuvé par
monsieur bédié votre président du
conseil départemental
il ne me dit tu vas ne me dites pas le
contraire parce que les textes sont là
les écrits sont là les courriers sont
présents donc moi je veux bien tout ce
que vous dites mais quand même sur la
question du nombre on n'est pas il faut
être clair sur la zac bécane il faut
pour qu'elle soit attractive pour qu'on
puisse créer du commerce et qu'on puisse
créer des équipements publics
il nous faut atteindre les chiffres de
1500 logements sinon vous l'aurez pas
vous aurez pas d'attractivité et vous
n'aurez pas d'équipements publics je
rajoute que dans ce que ce qui était dit
là c'est pas cité ses histoires
d'équipements publics
or on en a besoin je discutais avec la
mairesse 2010 saint denis qui me disait
quand vous ferez gare bécane vous ferez
sûrement un gymnase et si vous faites un
gymnase vous pourrez peut-être nous
votre cd celui que nous avons donc si
bon voilà c'est des choses comme ça
qu'on peut qu'on peut trouver et donc
les nécessités là de penser à aux
équipements publics qui permettrait de
donner de l'attractivité à ce quartier
on n'est pas sûr sur une petite affaire
la question
de l'aménagement de ce quartier répond
aussi à la demande du grand paris vous
avez un rapport qui est sorti sur
l'aménagement des gares du grand paris
qui dit très bien et très clairement
ceci il faut en effet densifier un peu
autour des gares pour pouvoir faire
répond aussi à la question
environnementale
voilà et donc nous on est dans la
proposition qui avait été faite dans la
proposition calvet honoré partant
pression par l'est sur les autres
dossiers vous êtes déjà plus de cinq
minutes en étant arrivé après excusez
moi je suis nécessairement obligé de
d'expliquer aussi pour ceux qui nous
suivent ce radeau sensations je donne
les indications de temps jean yves blé
vous êtes à 5 minutes 12 nicolas
dainville quatre minutes 40 ml duthu
trois minutes 53 nicolas mainville
devrait juste vous faire réagir parce
que plusieurs fois vous avez été
mentionné une idée du tout si vous
souhaitez vous exprimer à nouveau pour
rattraper ce temps de retard sinon après
nous passerons une autre thématique
nicolas dainville effectivement on a des
aménagements qui sont très importants on
pourrait citer aussi l'aménagement de la
rénovation urbaine d'orly parc qui a été
voté au département ces deux millions
d'euros qui vont être investis qui sont
importants il y avait un sentiment
d'abandon chez beaucoup d'habitants
notamment hill park 2 et puis orly parc
1-1 sur ce que vous dites monsieur blé
il faut savoir que pour le nouveau
projet y aura plus 30 % d'activité
économique le long de cette rn 10
c'était prévu mais s'il ya + 30 % etc si
ça m'était le cas prévu monsieur pour
terminer le dossier alcatel par exemple
et les échanges avec veolia on aurait
peut-être plus là vous auriez peut-être
plus là elle agir et faire en sorte que
ce domaine là deviennent plus
attractives d'un point de vue technique
donc plus 30% effectivement cette fête
1096 que ce bâtiment et me connaît bien
le cas vers évident c'est quand même un
effectivement un élément de bilan quai
paquet pas glorieux mais effectivement
équilibré et il faut pas répondre à des
enjeux uniquement de promotion
immobilière ou financier faut penser à
la qualité on aux portes de la vallée de
chevreuse et donc je pense que les
habitants sont pas attachés à quelque
chose de dense mais à quelque chose qui
respecte ce fameux esprit village auquel
on est tous attachés de l'éco quartier
qui était présentée était tout à fait
équilibré giroud lafeber monsieur blé
nelly duthu oui vous souhaitez réagir
jugement
sur cette thématique voulez boire un
verre d'eau si vous voulez voilà la
problématique des du nombre de logements
pour moi aujourd'hui est un petit peu
non avenue le premier projet c'était
1000 milles entre 1800 et 1500 ans 15 20
ans le premier le deuxième projet est
mille logements en 12 ans les 1000
logements en 12 ans que ce soit sur le
premier ou deuxième projet ça ne change
strictement rien donc on a le temps de
voir sur les mille projets en disant on
met tout le monde d'accord c'est de
toute façon pas plus de logements qui
pourraient elles sortir de terre donc
voilà quant à monsieur alcatel et
monsieur feuillatte qui profite et
propriété avec un prix de vente très
élevés 65 $ village qui en son temps le
l'agglomération essayé en son temps tout
le monde a essayé mais je pense qu'on
peut trouver les voix une voix une issue
de secours avec notamment valeo qui peut
atteindre se développer à condition de
trouver voilà le bon arrangement
puisqu'ils vont effectivement bâtiments
de manière excessivement cher 65
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ni duthu
vous allez terminer
alors passons à une autre une autre
thématique effectivement ce dossier
d'urbanisme qui est important ce n'est
pas le seul pendant cette campagne des
municipales
nous pouvons parler également
d'éducation éducation à présent on va
débuter avec vue nelly dis-tu vous avez
un peu moins de cinq minutes donc à peu
près 30 secondes de retard 40 secondes
de retard sur les autres
vos propositions concernant l'éducation
vous voulez mettre l'accent vous le
dites dans votre programme élargir le
temps périscolaire soutien scolaire
gratuit pour tout soutien aux étudiants
par diverses bourses aussi vous allez
quelques unes de vos propositions
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
vous aujourd'hui c'est continuer à
à faire en sorte que les ducs parce que
la réussite scolaire c'est pas que
l'école l'école c'est chez les
enseignants c'est l'éducation nationale
la ville est la plus à un rôle
d'éducation danse dans la synergie qu'on
peut trouver entre l'école nos propres
activités
nos propres services et les partenaires
je crois beaucoup je suis je sors de
l'éducation populaire
j'ai fait tout mon chemin je teins début
de carrière avec les cemea des
associations d'éducation populaire
j'y crois énormément je pense qu'il faut
à côté de l'enseignement et pour que
l'enfant soit le mieux possible
armée dans les classes qu'à côté il y
ait à un ensemble d'activités un
ensemble de propositions culturelles
sportives et autres qu'ils fassent en
sorte que l'enfant puisse s'épanouir
grandir et s'enrichir d'un maximum
d'informations mais aussi de
d'expression
individuels et artistique donc c'est un
ensemble l'éducation c'est pas de
l'émiettement par ci par là c'est un
ensemble de choses qu'il faut qui fait
que l'enfant est armé pour aller à
l'école et le problème de nos de nos
villes populaires
cette légalité des territoires n'existe
pas vous avez des villes beaucoup plus
plus aisé on va dire avec un potentiel
culturel éducatif bien plus important et
comme l'éducation nationale ne fait pas
la différence et met tout le monde au
même niveau c'est un nouveau ville de
récupérer
est ce qui manque et d'offrir ce service
là aux enfants jean-yves les vos
différentes propositions concernant
l'éducation dans votre programme j'ai
cru voir aussi de réunir les deux écoles
aussi faire un seul groupe scolaire
cette partie de vos projets ça c'est
dans le cadre du plan de rénovation
urbaine sur le mode est en effet non
concernant concernant l'école vous savez
on était en zone d'éducation prioritaire
qui nous étaient retirés pour des
questions
des clips pas d'équilibré de de moyens
financiers entre la population de la
verrière et celle du mini quand on
faisait le ratio on était supérieurs par
rapport à la tranche qui permet de
rester dans la zone d'éducation
prioritaire
on s'est battu pour avoir une convention
académique de priorité éducative qui a
été pour l'instant qui n'a plus lieu
puisqu'il est arrivé à terme en juin
l'année dernière nous souhaitons nous
relancer cette discussion là parce que
ce sont des moyens qui sont attribués à
l'école qui sont importants et qui
permettent de garder des élèves des
classes à 25 ce qui nous semble nous
essentiels concernant notre population
donc on va on va mettre l'accent sur ce
dispositif là qui est pour nous
fondamentale sur l'ensemble après on a
et j'ai bataillé mois pour la question
du numérique parce que je sais que c'est
une question qui taraude aussi notre ami
monsieur la ville dans ce domaine là
j'ai bataillé pour obtenir les chariots
numérique qu'on a mis en place sur nos
écoles et c'est bien que ce plan
numérique est arrivé en fin d'année
dernière me semble utile pour l'ensemble
des communes de l'agglomération
c'est un c'est un outil qu'il faudra sur
lequel il faudra se montrer attentif on
a un
une pensée aussi un une réflexion
concernant l'accompagnement scolaire est
donc là on va travailler à mettre en
place des études dirigées parce que ça
nous semble important que les enfants
soient accompagnés et notamment les
nôtres pour l'aide aux devoirs de
manière à ce qu'ils ne soient pas en
décalage avec les autres villes d'à côté
parce que c'est aussi ça notre commune
vous savez que dans la question du pis
ça c'est pas tant le niveau scolaire des
élèves français qui est une remise en
question c'est l'organisation sociétale
qui remis en question c'est à dire que
on a des secteurs très riche où une
population aisée peut se permettre un
certain nombre de choses et des secteurs
très pau où là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et donc il a cessé sa que met
en avant dix à aimer pas en avant la
question du savoir la question
je suis désolé mais deux minutes j'ai
obligé de les interrompre sinon vous
n'aurez pas le temps pour vous exprimer
sur les autres sujets alesi nous devons
veiller en ces temps de campagne
électorale à une égalité et c'est bien
normal sinon entre les candidats savent
où nicolas d'envié effectivement
l'éducation c'est la priorité des
priorités c'est l'avenir de la verrière
alors monsieur blé vous parlez du
classement pisa ça fait mans ce
classement des pays les plus performants
d'un point de vue scolaire
quand on regarde ce classement il
ressort deux choses c'est que les pays
qui réussissent le mieux à faire réussir
leurs enfants c'est la formation des
enseignants pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
mette le paquet là-dessus et c'est
l'implication des enfants dans leur
apprentissage plus l'élève est impliqué
mieux il apprend et donc moi c'est mon
ambition avec mon équipe c'est grâce aux
nouveaux outils innovants aux outils
innovants mis en place notamment par le
département qui sont pas uniquement et
c'est peut-être ça qui nous différencie
une livraison de matériel
c'est une nouvelle pédagogie qu'il faut
mettre en place avec nos enseignants il
faut qu'ils soient formés pour ça pour
rendre cette pédagogie plus interactive
que les élèves participent plus plus
collaborative qui travaillent en groupe
et plus personnalisés
qu'on s'adapte au rythme de chacun aux
élèves composent besoin d'un peu plus de
temps ce qu'ils avancent un peu plus
vite voilà on grâce aux nouveaux outils
aux tablettes numériques au cours
d'anglais par visioconférence qui
forment à la bonne oreille aux tableaux
numériques interactifs au cours dé
chaque qui forment aussi à la pensée
logique et mathématique grâce à tous ces
outils on peut vraiment avoir plus
d'égalité des chances à l'école plus de
réussite scolaire et ça c'est vraiment
notre ambition n'est du genre passe la
parole pour peut-être aussi glissé vers
la thématique de l'emploi parce qu'on
parle d'éducation éducation emploi
formation ça commence très jeune mais
ensuite il faut aussi accompagner les
populations aujourd'hui en recherche
d'emploi et un fort taux de chômage sur
la commune plus de formation pour aider
au retour à l'emploi position contre à
ça mais juste à lézinnes un tout petit
pont pas aborder toutes les thématiques
je vous préviens déjà quand monsieur blé
dit j'ai bataillé pour avoir de
numérique je ne sais pas avec qui contre
qui il a bataillé
à l'époque je pense qu'on était dans la
même majorité et que le numérique
rentrée à l'école date de pierce
élincourt donc ça fait un moment que
c'est sur la vie j'aime rire et ça fait
1 ça fait pas mal mais pas des tableaux
numériques les tableaux numériques en
effet décidé à l'entendre dans le même
conseil oui mais il a fallu que
j'insiste lourdement auprès des services
auprès de toi pour que ça se mette en
oeuvre
excuse moi c'est tout c'est comme ça
c'est une réalité c'est pas grave oui
bon bah je connais je connais ça je
connais si ta position concernant le
visible vous partagiez pas non plus
d'accord
je n'étais pas la peine mais en tout cas
je pense que c'est parce que si je
n'avais pas été d'accord ça n'aurait
jamais été votée parce que sinon
j'aurais jamais été sur la table du
conseil municipal
donc voilà c'est parce qu'on a dû
dévoiler pour votre réponse
d'autre part vous parlez beaucoup de
formation de l'enseignant
je suis d'accord mais c'est pas là
l'échelle ne s'est pas l'échelle de la
ville on est d'accord il ya le problème
un petit peu non sous ses yeux le
nouveau centre de formation à nantes je
sais je sais et du coup mais le nouveau
centre ont déjà d'ouvrir son nationale
c'est l'éducation nationale nous c'est
pas dans l'éducation nationale qu'on
affiche pas d'accord avec vous
code-barres voilà et nous c'est à côté
qu'on agit c'est dans l'ordre en
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale
est pas ça c'est sûr vous êtes vous êtes
partiellement raison à l'intérieur j'ai
partiellement raison et d'ailleurs quand
vous faisiez différents cas vous faisait
référence à l'éducation nationale et ses
moyens peut-être trop uniforme et
paraissait équitable
c'était aussi apprennent nationale mais
il ya nouveau centre de formation qui
vient d'ouvrir à elancourt pour
justement les enseignants yvelinois du
premier degré c'est aussi ce type de
partenaires qu'il faut mobiliser pour
former nos anciens monsieur d'henvic je
tiens énormément à ce que l'éducation
nationale reste un service public de
l'éducation nationale et ne passe pas au
privé comme on partage cet avis mehdi
d'études sur la forme sur l'emploi sur
la formation l'emploi prioritaire aussi
dans votre programme comme pour les
autres la cave ou pour y exposer vos
propositions et j'aimerais qu'on regarde
un peu de temps pour parler de la
sécurité aussi qui est un dossier
important pour cette commune de la
verrière donc si brièvement vous pouviez
me parlez de vos propositions concernant
l'emploi oui bien sûr puisque
effectivement on a on a fait des choses
sur l'emploi sur l'accompagnement des
jeunes à l'emploi les forums etc
ce fonds je pense qu'ils aujourd'hui il
faut passer à une vitesse supérieure
dans
dans l'accompagnement à l'emploi on a
trop de jeunes laissés sur le bas côté
donc effectivement on met le
on met des moyens qu'on n'avait pas mis
jusqu'à maintenant sur l'emploi tels que
un chargé de mission qui va naître que
sur sur cette question de
l'accompagnement des gens à la recherche
de l'emploi ou d'insertion ou de
formation ou de stage parce qu'il ya
énormément de possibilités donc une
personne qui va venir spécifiquement là
dessus on a aussi loc
l'objectif de créer une régie de
quartier pour effectivement aider à
l'insertion
ça ce sont les deux gros les deux gros
morceaux et je me tais puisque je suis
navré il faut essayer tous à égalité
dans rien monsieur bhl est justement
vous avez une minute à peu près pour
rééquilibrer le temps de parole
j'aimerais vous parler de votre
proposition forte
on n'est pas là pour chacun des
candidats et surtout les débats pour
présenter l'ensemble bien évidemment
mais la proposition n'a pas on n'a pas
de propositions fortes concernant
l'emploi parce que tout simplement c'est
pas de la compétence de la mine l'emploi
il ya des structures pour ça vous avez
la force nationale pour l'emploi le pôle
emploi c'est plus là un peu merci fait
je reste moi sur de vieux schémas et
vous avez concernant les jeunes la
mission locale
moi je compte m'appuyer sur ces
structures qui existent pour répondre à
cette problématique de l'emploi qui est
une problématique importante mais je
vous dis une fois encore il y à des
structures pour 16 pour cela et il faut
impliquer ses structures dans
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
en termes de réponse sur le territoire
vous avez l'école de la deuxième chance
vous avez un dispositif avec les
compétences vous avez le cfm btp vous
avez les outils vous les outils on les a
sur le territoire il fut il suffit
simplement de faire de la synergie des
synergies entre eux avec la collectivité
de manière à répondre à cette
problématique là mais une fois encore je
ne pense pas que ce soit à la commune de
faire elle peut accompagner
elle peut apporter une contribution mais
ce n'est pas de sa compétence je pense
que la compétence de la commune c'est ce
qui la concerne sur son propre
territoire
la con la question de l'emploi c'est une
question générale globale
et ils doivent être traités de cette
manière là vous êtes à peu près à 10
minutes en élite du jean yves les ce qui
n'est pas le cas de nicolas dainville
geste réponse conserver un emploi vous
avez cinq minutes à peu près 16 % de
chômage uniquement pour la catégorie à
quand on regarde tous les inscrits à
pôle emploi j'ai regardé les chiffres
hier encore on a quasiment 600 inscrits
à pôle emploi sur notre commune c'est un
taux de chômage toutes catégories à 22%
donc effectivement la commune peut pas
rester les bras croisés il faut prendre
le taureau par les cornes
il faut mobiliser tous les moyens dont
dispose l'agglomération et en faire
bénéficier nos demandeurs d'emploi je
pense notamment à ce qu'ils emploient au
vélodrome nationale 27 février prochain
cinq mille offres d'emploi nous si on
est aux responsabilités on aimerait bien
préparer nos jeunes à réussir cette
journée et voir les accompagner comme
dans d'autres communes magny les hameaux
par exemple le fait très bien
et puis il ya un thème qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est
s'inspirer de ce qu'a mis en place
mustapha larbaoui à trappes il s'appelle
l'école de commerce de tracter un
programme qu'on aimerait bien nous aussi
initié au niveau municipal l'école de
commerce de la verrière pour transmettre
les codes de l'entreprise pour un
accompagnement personnalisé sur les cv
mais aussi sur les entretiens de
recrutement il ya des des petits trucs à
savoir qu'ils peuvent faire la
différence et ouvrir des perspectives
assez jeune on a aujourd'hui on le voit
une génération à peu abandonnée je
dirais des des 19 20 25 ans qui
aujourd'hui est un peu livrée à
elle-même et c'est grave
il faut qu'on arrive à les capter dans
ce type de programme pour leur ouvrir
des horizons mettre en avant des
parcours de réussite leur donner aussi
quelques horizons positif
et puis lors lors leur ouvrir leur
ouvrir les champs des possibles
dernier point important le mentorat on
aimerait bien que un salarié des
salariés saint quentinois soit des
mentors de jeunes verts hyérois pour
ouvrir l'expérience leur expérience et
surtout leur réseau puisqu'aujourd'hui
on sait que c'est fondamental d'avoir du
réseau
nicolas mainville vous avez rattrapé
votre temps de retard vous êtes tous
entre 9 minutes 30 et 10 minutes de
temps de parole
ce débat va arriver à sa fin pour ceux
qui nous suivent en direct vous le savez
tout au long de la journée aujourd'hui
vous avez des débats à suivre sur tv 78
nous allons donc
voir conclure je propose chacun de
prendre deux minutes pour faire votre
conclusion est abordée peut-être ce
thème de la sécurité qui nous avions
prévu que nous n'avons pas eu le temps
de développer mais bien sûr je renvoie
aussi à vos différents rendez-vous
meeting distribution de tracts et et
autres rendez vous sur internet pour
faire part de vos programmes et pour que
les les électeurs de la verrière
retrouve les différentes propositions
qui peuvent les intéresser donc pour la
conclusion
on va débuter avec avec vous jean yves
blais parce que vous m'avez fait un
tirage au sort avant que vous n'arriviez
vous n'étiez pas là et donc vous allez
commencer
écoutez nous on est en train de
travailler à la finalité notre programme
on et demain on a une journée complète
de travail à ce sujet là notre slogan
c'est vivre et décider ensemble sur la
verrière et on va travailler à ça on est
je crois une équipe là diverses
culturellement éthiquement et
éthiquement socialement avec des gens
volontaires jeunes qui veulent faire
bouger la commune on va vraiment essayer
de redonner à cette ville une place
qu'elle mérite au coeur de saint quentin
en yvelines de manière à faire en sorte
que les gens n'aient pas envie
aujourd'hui comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui de la quitter mais plutôt
d'y rester voilà c'est à ça qu'on va
s'attacher et pour nous c'est un
challenge qui pas
qui pavent qui va pas être facile mais
sur lequel on croit nicolas mainville un
petit point sur l'insécurité puisque
c'est comme un thème bien effectivement
train d'incivilité avec tout un tas de
petites choses mais qui peuvent pourrir
la vie du quotidien fameuses voitures
ventouses les fameuses mécanique
sauvages les poubelles prime de propreté
donc il faut qu'on y luttent avec plus
de fermeté parce que sinon ça crée un
sentiment d'impunité avec des gens qui
respectent les règles qui ont ras-le-bol
que ceux qui ne respectent pas soient
pas sanctionnés il faut qu'on mobilise
nos médiateurs sociaux on à la verrière
loi deux médiateurs sociaux qui n'ont
pas été mobilisés pendant de trop
nombreuses années
il faut qu'on travaille sur cet
accompagnement social moi je dirais que
la chance pour la verrière les
historiques il ya un alignement des
planètes entre l'agglomération le
département la région et si on veut
débloquer des dossiers comme jamais on a
pu le faire il faut qu'on soit aligné
avec la ville on a une équipe motivée et
déterminée sous des cas envie de rendre
aussi au virois la fierté qu'ils
auraient peut-être jamais dû perdre né
du tube pour votre conclusion
alors d'abord
enfin c'est vous qui dites que la fierté
n'est perdu parce que les verrières moi
eux se sentent très fier d'être derrière
moi et très fier d'eux mêmes jeux et
excusez moi mais quand j'ai dit qu'il
avait des dossiers à bouger oui non non
non non non on parle vous venez de
parler de fierté et tous l'ont voilà
deux tueurs donc bref et quand vous
parlez d'emplois que l'agglomération
commence à redonner aussi des ff qui
fait des qui fait des permanents chez
nous sur l'emploi et qui a perdu la
moitié de sa subvention que laquelle
l'agglomération commence par vous
donnant à l'économie sociale
non non c'est pas non c'est pas dans vos
derniers soient nés du tout vous allez
faire votre transfert du coup oui oui
oui mais c'est facile de dire les choses
alors moi je vais éviter la la
concordance des planètes si vous le
permettez
parce qu'aujourd'hui la politique aussi
bien du département que de
l'agglomération n'est ni social ni pour
les associations
donc on va essayer de de ne pas faire ce
que vous dites
parce que je pense que socialement et
culturellement on y perdrait beaucoup
donc aujourd'hui mois reste dix secondes
oui bah les 10 secondes on a nagé en a
fait une équipe là aujourd'hui avec des
gens qui sont de terrain qui sont de la
ville qui sont nés ici qu'ils sont
jeunes il ya 44 % de jeunes de moins de
40 ans dans cette équipe d'aider des
gens expérimentés des gens qui ont
pas l'expérience mail envie que ça bouge
et que ça change je pense que j'ai une
très belle équipe et que je voudrais
vous avez gagné
je vous arrête là pour ceux ayant plus
ou moins équilibrés sur les temps de
paroles qui s'affichent nicolas
dainville nous avait un peu plus de
retard 10 minutes 44 11 minutes pour
monsieur blé 11 minutes 26 pour nelly du
tube bien sûr la campagne se poursuit
nous aurons l'occasion de vous redonner
ses trente secondes de retard au cours
des différents reportages et nous aurons
légalité comme à chaque fois
voilà merci merci en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce débat du premier tour je
rappelle aussi qu'il ya une quatrième
liste en cours de constitution
aujourd'hui assez celle de gérard claude
morfin qui n'a pas souhaité participer
au débat débat dépôt pardon des
candidatures en préfecture au plus tard
le 27 février à bientôt sur tv 78 radio
sensations pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]